[Music]
and welcome back everybody Thursday
marked day four in Laredo Texas in the
capital murder trial of Ronald Burgos
Aviles the former border patrol officer
faces the death penalty in a double
homicide that prosecutors allege was
over child support money Virgo saviles
was married with his own children when
he had a child with 28 year old Griselda
Hernandez in an alleged Affair in March
of 2018 Hernandez reportedly served the
FED to defend in child support documents
at his workplace and a month later
police say the defendant asked Hernandez
to see their almost two-year-old son and
they set up a meeting in a remote area
near a park prosecutors believe the
defendant stabbed Hernandez and that
little boy to death on that visit to
avoid paying child support a majority of
Thursday saw a lengthy daubert hearing
about whether one cell phone expert for
the state and another for the defense
would be allowed to testify in front of
the jury but let's go back to the end of
Wednesday because crucial footage of the
defendant was shown in court he was in
the back of a police squad car on the
day of the murders and showed some
strange Behavior to law enforcement
while being detained here's the footage
and what one police officer had to say
on the stand
he says hey man what's your name and
then burgo says
Aviles he only uses his last he only
uses his last names so then
um Rick's like
what's your name dude why are you not
telling me your name what's your name
and he says my name is Ronald burroless
and he says
you're not telling me your name do you
have an idea or something and he's just
he's like no I don't have an ID
okay
what is it what is that he's doing in
that
scene he's wiping his arms looks like
he's
cleaning something off or what was it
that he did right before
he licked his finger so we parked in the
sally port
um I got off I was a riding passenger so
I got off the vehicle and I opened the
door for him I tell him to step out he
steps out and he immediately turns
around and puts his hands behind his
back and I asked him what are you doing
man and he's like well I know the dude I
know the drill I know the deal and I was
like you're not under arrest or you're
just being detained you just gotta clear
your name that's exactly what I don't
know hmm so was he anticipating that he
was going to be arrested I mean Brian
what was do you think he was rubbing off
on his arm the camp prosecution can't
say for sure I think that's even useful
to them that point
I won't lie Jesse when I first heard the
rubbing of the arm I guess my issue is
that I thought this
yeah yeah like he was trying like like
getting blood out or getting us into the
dirt or whatever but that seems a little
innocuous even just just like
that that
enough for me now I know what the
process is going to do consciousness of
guilt he's trying to get rid of some
evidence but that to me I I don't know
what what is that rubbing what would you
be able to get out with that so it's
going to be up for debate you're going
to see what you want to see and either
side will be able to to use that
perception towards it to helping their
side yeah he might have licked his hand
to get rid of it too I mean Melba how do
you think the prosecution is going to
use that video and the defendant's
behavior against him is there anything
really the defense can push back on that
I don't think that there's a well first
of all I think the defense can
definitely say that well this is a
nothing Burger you know uh they weren't
able to identify what it was he was
rubbing they didn't the officer didn't
notice anything on him any blood or
stains or anything when he placed him in
his car so they can kind of go after the
police officer's creditability that way
saying well if you didn't observe
anything or if you thought there was
blood or something else you would have
taken a picture you would have taken
steps to preserve that evidence so there
is a path across examination there but
at the same token means behavior in
terms of yeah just arrest me you know I
know the drill I know what's about to
happen well is that consciousness of
guilt and secondly him rubbing so much
there we know there were multiple stab
wounds on both of the victims there is
that possibility of blood splatter so
you know there's arguments to be made
either way yeah it's I don't think it's
going to be the game changer but if
you're feeling he's guilty you use it
against them if you feel he's innocent
my ignore it when we come back multiple
confessions on a recorded phone line
what new court documents reveal about
the Delphi Indiana murder suspect and
why his defense team says it's a sign of
his poor Mental Health
[Music]
foreign
welcome back brand new documents give us
a look inside the mind of murder suspect
Richard Allen the man accused of killing
two teen girls in Delphi Indiana state
police arrested Allen last October for
the deaths of 13-year-old Abby Williams
and 14 year old Libby German the two
girls didn't show up to a planned
meeting after they went for a walk on
the Delphi historic trails in February
of 2017 and the next day their bodies
were found in the woods near that trail
on Wednesday the judge released more
than 100 court documents one of those
documents says that Allen admitted to
his wife that he killed both of those
girls this alleged confession happened
on a recorded phone call from the
correctional facility that Allen was
housed in he apparently made the
admission at least five times on the
call his wife quickly hung up the
defense says that after that phone call
Allen's mental health declined sharply
they say that he started wetting down
the documents given to him by his legal
team and eating them his lawyers say
that any confessions he made were
because of his poor mental health in
other court documents we learned the
girls were killed were killed by a sharp
object and prosecutors believed the
knife was used but it was a bullet that
connected Alan to the crime scene an
unspent 40 caliber round was found less
than two feet from German's body between
the two girls that bullet was connected
back to Allen who had admitted to being
at the trail the day of the murder so
let's break this down Melba can
prosecutors use a private call between
the defendant and his wife against him
in this situation yes because this was a
recorded jail call so if you call
somebody who's in in custody usually a
little message starts off saying this is
a recorded line this is your warning
that don't say anything that you don't
want to later on here in the courtroom
uh you know once trial begins I'm sure
that that warning was given the
defendant went ahead and made the
statements that he did so as such that
can be used in trial when I was a
prosecutor I used to love jail calls
because again people always ignored that
admonishment in the beginning that this
is a recorded call so in this situation
he may be out of gas unless there's some
sort of mental health argument which
again I don't think may be successful in
this portion the question is you see
competence yeah because prosecutors say
he might have been faking it uh his
behavior after that call realizing oops
I probably shouldn't have done that but
it does raise an interesting question
Brian of Competency because this kind of
behavior is pretty erratic so what
should we be thinking about how a court
would measure Allen's competency to
stand trial well of course a judge will
get him evaluated to have a professional
actually speak to Alan and see what's
going on inside of his head the issue
that I think is going to be really at
the Forefront here is the timeline it
doesn't seem like his mental health was
declining and then he made the statement
it makes it seem like he made the
statement multiple times I think about
five times as you said and then his wife
hangs up he never calls his wife again
and speaks with her in this kind of way
and then he's eating papers I mean I
jokingly said it to you before Jesse if
you're going to try to go for the
insanity defense there's a lot of things
you could be eating in a jail that makes
it seem a lot crazier than your own
paper but he didn't go that route I
don't think this is really going to work
out for him just because of the timeline
of how things laid out but hey get the
evaluation and and make the argument and
by the way he could be acting erratic in
jail it all matters what was his mental
state on the day of the killings if
we're going to be talking about insanity
Melba Brian thank you so much everyone
out there thanks for joining us here on
Long crime daily we will see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America
[Music]
foreign